- So it appears that the emoluments cases
against Former President Trump
have now all been dismissed as moot.
And while a lot of people are upset,
it's not as crazy as it seems
because federal courts have requirement
that all cases have to
be a case in controversy.
So, the court can't decide things
where it doesn't have
any power to do anything.
And if you're thinking, "Well
he still made all that money
while he was president,"
you're right except that
a lot of these cases,
if not all of them, didn't
actually seek damages.
They sought perspective relief.
They sought to stop him from
doing stuff in the future.
They didn't actually
seek retrospective relief
to get him to disgorge
the benefits that he had.
And since Trump is no longer president,
there's really nothing
that the courts can do now.
That being said, it does
leave open the possibility
that someone, maybe the Biden DOJ,
might go after President Trump for damages
and force him to disgorge those benefits.
Though there's always
the question of standing.
So stay tuned, and I'll see you in court.